oh my gosh we're here
that is our hotel so you put the code in
[Music]
oh my goodness if you want to go to stay
in a hotel
okay if you want to go and stay in a
hotel in
okay twa-10 if you've got a conference
in tw18
that's what you type in hotels in tw18
now i'm talking right now about service
accommodation how do you rent out your
property
as service accommodation how do you get
maximum super rent
well you've got to list it on
booking.com
because if you list it on booking.com
these are trav online travel agents
lastminute.com
kayak hotels.uk booking.com tripadvisor
these
are online travel agencies you can
literally
get a property a normal house not not
i'm not talking about
being owning a hotel you can have
a place listed on booking.com and
and have a hotel by literally just
renting out your house some of these
properties by the way
are just houses some of these properties
are houses they are
not hotels i mean look that is pretty
much a house it's called
the bolling hotel but it's just a it's
just it's just a house
it's a building and the reason some of
these guys aren't renting out very well
by the way
i mean some you can see all the
different prices here you know 183
40 right down to 444 that is
trying to attract tourists but tourism
is dead
guaranteed these people are trying to
attract business people nice
nice hotel now tw18 which
hotels how do you make yours come up at
the top well because i've got a friend
i've got a friend who's got a hotel it's
actually just an apartment
he doesn't even own this apartment his
name is on my academy
and he rents an apartment in an
apartment block
but then he's got a management agreement
which says that he can then list it on
booking.com so what he does is he pays
the landlord
a guaranteed rent each month and
now he lists it on booking.com this is
it little little apartment
and then he's getting bookings well i
say that he's literally just got the
keys to this
he's literally just listed this on
booking.com and
i'm going to go and check it out and i'm
going to see look it says it's sold out
well i can so funny isn't it that we can
read it without reading it it's in a
foreign language but i just know what it
means because it's got that redness
there
um sorry for you just a disappointment
ah it's gone anyway it's gone it's sold
out because i have just booked it
how do i how do you book it you book it
on booking.com how do you get on
booking.com you can literally list your
property on
booking.com it's not that difficult and
how do you make sure that your property
comes up right at the top
well do you have to pay loads of money
no you just have to get lots of reviews
if you get lots of reviews and you make
you ask your guests to leave your kind
reviews
then what happens is the online travel
agents google booking.com
start pushing your property up so what
this guy is needs to do
is very simply he needs to he's got he's
got his property that's great he secured
his rent to rent but now
the work begins now he has to get
customers he has to get bookings
he has to make sure the the the guests
leave good reviews
but this is a really good way to get a
lot of cash flow
serviced accommodation it's like a hotel
without staff so let's go
i'm gonna go and stay at his property
right now and i'm gonna review it not
just for you and show you how the
process works but i'm also gonna leave
him a review so let's hope i have a good
time
um i'm sure i will do it i'm not going
alone by the way i'm going with the
amazing
amanda leeds hi what are you expecting
the best the best you know even where
we're going or what's happening at all
well i have a little bit of an idea
so we're going to be staying in his
apartment do you think it'd be better or
worse than just staying in a normal
hotel
probably better i think he'll be better
yeah let's go let's go find out let's go
so we haven't had much cause we're just
going for one night it's just
everything yep i've got like
clothes in here though right
yeah okay cool
what i love about served accommodation
yeah is
how you don't have to faff around
waiting to check in when
and even though you've booked and most
of the time you pay yes
they still make you hang around have to
sign
sometimes like that time is money and
you can be standing there for 10 minutes
yeah waiting to sign this and sign that
with service accommodation in fact what
is the process so we booked the thing on
booking.com yeah
you get an automated email yeah which
what i mean
it was it was all automated um all the
information about the apartment
and any key safe codes any apps that you
need to download everything so you kind
of do everything
from the comfort of your own home
so we're here that is our hotel
it has like a little map that direction
shows you where you're supposed to be
going
okay so you put the code in and then
and then bother these cars like
15 pounds um and you get them from argos
okay so that's great and then what do we
do we use this to get in the house and
everything
no we use that to get into the basement
oh and then what do we do
park the car and then we get into the
hat and then we go okay
you can tell when we get there
that's number 10 there sir awesome
all right let's go to the apartment
there so is there another key to the
apartment
my phone what oh yeah
so no silly hotel checking so there's
that little tiny bit of fat
you've got to get out you've got to get
the key but i would rather do that
any day than now just maybe queue
and sign and wait you know i mean often
honestly hotels you can be waiting five
minutes just for someone to come and see
you
and then they're like you know get you
this and you're gonna get your car and
mess around
takes forever this is easy i'm not am i
yeah you're right where are we going
doesn't matter
[Music]
this is honestly no different from when
you're a hotel you're looking for your
room number it really is yeah
it's just the same so we are first floor
okay so we've got to go yeah well we can
go to the lift
yeah this is no different from a hotel
so this is an apartment block being
rented out as a hotel but the current
landlord
was asking for the price of a normal ast
contract
uh well that was like a grand a month or
whatever but he's renting it out for the
price of a hotel which is what like a
hundred pound an alley
maybe more if there's lots of people
with the zip beds i find this is how we
get in so there's this app
called clevia where is it where is it
okay
is that awkward to download it was that
no no it's really easy two seconds
oh my goodness this dude aceto what is
he like
okay let's look around this place man
who showed me around i have been around
before but when i came before it was uh
what was this what's this
welcome to first guest i feel like i
should have the scissors to like
where shall i start just show me around
just take some
scissors here we go
oh wow oh my gosh this
is so lovely this is quicker and easier
and better than a hotel
quicker better easier oh yeah nice
this is where we're going to sleep in
here
[Music]
come on in i'm just looking for the
light okay this is not the main bedroom
this is oh because it is a two-bedroom
yeah but here's the crazy thing
it's very nice but here's the crazy
thing okay this you've got two
two beds but these beds are zip beds
so you can put them together and zip
them up
i don't want to mess the bed up anyway
because we're not going to be using them
yeah
but listen you can turn this into a
double bed which just means let's say me
and amanda were coming but we were also
wanting to come with
another couple that wanted to share a
bed
then they could put these together and
zip them up so
this is a twin room or a double room it
can be whatever you want it to be
it can be whatever you want it to be see
this if we were staying in a hotel
we'd just be in a little bedroom a
little cramped bedroom but now we've got
all this space
we can literally have way more fun
just figure bathroom
okay nice bathroom
i love how it's got the personal touch
that needs to stay you need to get
cleaners
that will every time a guest moves out
they'll make you look back like this
so that people can come and you know
they can relax they can bathe
they can soak
this must be the master oh no it's not
it's the kitchen
oh nice that's nice nice
very good kitchen why do we get spice
you see here's another thing okay here's
another thing
i don't like eating hotels but there's
everyone all around and it's
i have to order i just want to just
relax order a takeaway
home from home so you've got cutlery and
stuff in here
which saves you and it's just better
it's better
service accommodation always book a
house service accommodation or an
apartment instead of a hotel
i really think that i'm selling service
accommodation right now okay
uh you know what the hotel business is
gonna be really struggling now
eight percent of london did you know
eight percent of greater london in
service accommodation
eight percent of greater london she's
pregnant by the way she's not just a
chicken tikka masala that'd be mean all
right show us the name show us the name
eight of gracer london service
accommodation this is our bedroom
wow how nice what a personal
touch oh that is lovely oh that's so
sweet
oh my goodness it's just like clean
fresh it is
lovely it is really nice
so we're gonna have we're gonna have a
lovely evening today yes we are comment
below would you rather stay
in this apartment okay this apartment
all to yourself
or in a hilton hotel where you're in one
little double bedroom that's it
noisy neighbours um and
you've got to check in and take forever
to check in what would you rather
comment
below comment below comment below this
was a one bed apartment i seem to
converted into a two bed this was just
space that wasn't a bedroom so he's
converted it
you get six people so what you're gonna
do with service accommodations you're
gonna charge
not per booking book per person and
you're gonna charge extra when extra
people stay so you can really make a lot
of money doing this this is going to be
a great
stay so far five stars for me asito and
asito is also one of my students so he's
on the academy
and nothing i prefer to do than support
academy members
so i'm gonna leave i'm not on commission
or anything i promise but i'm going to
leave a link
to this hotel this service department
if you want to come and stay i'm going
to leave a link below but this is
incredible really nice
my food is almost here i'm going to eat
i'm going to sleep
and then we're going to fast forward
i'll see you tomorrow morning
which will be in about five seconds
[Music]
so amanda told me to put the towel back
on the towel rack i'm sorry sweetie
that's not what you do because i'm tidy
yeah but you do things illogical when
you finish with a towel at a hotel
you put it on the floor yeah so people
know it's dirty and also you spent so
much time making the bed
that's pointless because the cleaners
just have to make the bed again
but it's tidy
samuel getting his socks on that's right
thank you so much for letting us stay
here in fact we've run quite a lot of
our training really close to here we've
got
we've actually got training today which
is going to be at the heathrow
this is how far is this from the from
that training 10 minutes less than 10
minutes away it's also really close to
thought park yeah yeah can the next
seven minutes
30 minutes three minutes three minutes
you hear that
three minutes um what what would you say
has been the most um
fun part of getting this place all ready
and kick it out well
the most uh fun part is obviously
getting the
all the all the furnitures in place
what were you expecting profit to make
from from this permanent 600 being
conservative
600 being conservative okay that's good
yeah we set a minimum of 500.
yeah yeah that's that's what we already
have to yeah
my calculation is pointing to 600
million worth case
uh obviously what about what about
likely case what are you hoping to
achieve
life because maybe 750 800 yeah
yeah yeah and having said that what's
uh the situation the world is seen yeah
in the middle of the plan as well um
keep us posted on the bookings how much
money you make because
it's a good case today yeah okay um are
you on to your next onto your next deal
now
uh already yes i'm looking at winsor
when is that
yeah i did one i got someone to review
one for me uh
last tuesday yeah and i'll put in an
offer waiting for the
for the feedback by tomorrow morning
yeah yeah yeah no it's good i'm happy
that you are you're the first guest yeah
i happen to be the first guest that
should come with
a blessing
so i'm as i say i'm going to leave a
link below if you want to come and stay
here at the sita's house
you can do that if you want to come and
meet me at my house on a discovery day
get to meet me
at my house in buckinghamshire i'll also
leave a link to a discovery day
as well where we can talk about your
plan your strategy and uh
overall 10 out of 10. great job respect
so that's it that is rent to service
accommodation where you rent a house
and then you list it on booking.com of
course you need the right permissions
you need the right training
if you want to be trained and you want
to learn all the legislation and stuff
i'll leave in the description the
training but you
rent it then you put it on airbnb
booking.com and you keep any profit as
monthly cash flow
don't own the property control the
property don't worry about capital
appreciation but get cash flow right now
i'll leave descriptions in the link also
please do me a massive favor and smash
the like button
also subscribe and i'll see you on the
next video peace out